In a world populated by 7 billion people,
Which person is the most typical?
The world's most typical person is
... right handed,
… Earns less than DKK 64,000 a year.
… Own a mobile phone
… But has no bank account.
Less than 25% of us do.
How does he look?
The world's most typical person is a man
There are more men than women
… But only straight
The average age of the world population is 28
The largest ethnic group he is Chinese
world
most typical person is
28-year-old he Chinese man.
There are over 9,000,000 of them
Scientists have used
photos of 190,000 of them
… To create a composite image
And here is the world's most typical peron
But he does not typically remain forever
In 2030, the person from India comes
And typically it is always relative
The typical Dutch man is 180 cm tall
In Peru he is 164 cm
In Japan, the typical woman lives until she is 86 years old.
In Afghanistan, she lives for 45 years
The typical American uses 380 liters of water
water into the home every day
In parts of Ethiopia, it is under 10 liters a day
And some women spend 8 hours a day picking it up.
Typical people have to make choices
But not everyone has the same opportunities
The decisions we make make a big difference
When you multiply them by 7 billion
7 billion on the planet. What does that mean for us?
A series of articles throughout 2011 in National Geographic